AT APPROXIMATELY 2:27 THIS
MORNING, SAN FRANCISCO POLICE
OFFICERS WERE DISPATCHED TO THE
RESIDENCE OF SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI REGARDING AN A PRIORITY
WELL-BEING CHECK.
WHEN THE OFFICERS ARRIVED ON
SCENE, THEY ENCOUNTERED AN ADULT
MALE AND MR. PELOSI'S HUSBAND,
PAUL.
OUR OFFICERS OBSERVED MR. PELOSI
AND SUSPECT BOTH HOLDING A
HAMMER.
THE SUSPECT PULLED THE HAMMER
AWAY FROM MR. PELOSI AND
VIOLENTLY ASSAULTED HIM WITH IT.
OUR OFFICERS IMMEDIATELY TACKLED
THE SUSPECT, DISARMED HIM, TOOK
HIM INTO CUSTODY, REQUESTED
EMERGENCY BACKUP AND RENDERED
MEDICAL AID.
THE SUSPECT HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED
AS 42-YEAR-OLD DAVID DEPEPI.
MR. PELOSI AND SUSPECT WERE
TRANSPORTED TO LOCAL HOSPITAL
FOR TREATMENT.
THIS IS AN ACTIVE INVESTIGATION
CURRENTLY BEING LED BY THE SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE DEPARTMENT
SPECIAL INVESTIGATIONS DIVISION.
WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH OUR
PARTNERS FROM THE FBI, THE U.S.
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE, THE U.S.
CAPITOL POLICE AND OUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY HERE IN SAN FRANCISCO
COUNTY, DEA BROOKE JENKINS AND
HER TEAM.
THE MOTIVE FOR THIS ATTACK IS
STILL BEING DETERMINED.
MR. DEPEPI WILL BE BOOKED AT SAN
FRANCISCO COUNTY JAIL ON THE
FOLLOWING CHARGES -- ATTEMPTED
HOMICIDE, ASSAULT WITH A DEADLY
WEAPON, ELDER ABUSE, VERBAL, AND
SEVERAL OTHER ADDITIONAL
FELONIES.
BEFORE I GO ANY FURTHER, I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE RESPONDING
OFFICERS FOR THEIR SWIFT ACTION
THIS MORNING.
THOSE SAN FRANCISCO POLICE
OFFICERS ARE OFFICER COLBY
WILMIS, OFFICER KYLE CAGNEY AND
SERGEANT EDMUND HUANG AND OUR
EMERGENCY DISPATCHER FOR A
REALLY AMAZING JOB.
FOR INQUIRIES REGARDING
MR. PELOSI AND HIS CONDITION, WE
REFER YOU TO THE STATEMENT
ISSUED BY SPEAKER PELOSI'S
OFFICE THIS MORNING.
AND WITH THAT, I'M GOING TO TURN
IT OVER TO OUR DISTRICT
ATTORNEY, BROOKE JENKINS FOR A
FEW BRIEF COMMENTS.
LET ME SAY IN ADVANCE, THIS IS
WHAT WE KNOW AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL UPDATE YOU FURTHER BUT WE
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS AFTER THIS STATEMENT.
>> THANK YOU, CHIEF SCOTT.
I DO WANT TO COMMEND THE SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE DEPARTMENT FOR
THEIR IMMEDIATE RESPONSE TO THIS
HOME AND FOR SWIFTLY MAKING SURE
THAT MR. PELOSI WAS OKAY AND
THAT THE SUSPECT WAS
APPREHENDED.
WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH THEM
RIGHT NOW WITH RESPECT TO THE
INVESTIGATION AND WILL PROCEED
WITH THE APPROPRIATE CHARGES AS
THINGS UNFOLD, AS LONG AS -- AS
WELL AS WORK WITH THE U.S.
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND OUR
FEDERAL PARTNERS.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE.
I KNOW YOU MAY HAVE -- WE'LL
UPDATE YOU WHEN WE HAVE MORE.
>> DO YOU KNOW HOW HE GOT INTO
THE HOUSE?
>> THAT'S IT FOR RIGHT NOW.
WE WON'T TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
OUR OFFICE WILL BE ISSUE, A NEWS
RELEASE VERY SOON.
THAT'S IT FOR NOW.
THANK YOU.
>> WE'LL WAIT FOR THAT NEWS
RELEASE IN THE HOPES OF LEARNING
MORE DETAILS.
A VERY, VERY BRIEF UPDATE PRESS
CONFERENCE WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE CHIEF.
BILL SCOTT, WHO TOLD US THAT
OFFICERS WERE DISPATCHED AROUND
220 LOCAL TIME THERE IN SAN
FRANCISCO TO THE HOME OF SPEAKER
NANCY PELOSI.
HER HUSBAND WAS THERE AT THE
TIME WHEN THEY ARRIVED WITH THE
SUSPECT.
HE SAID BOTH WERE HOLDING
HAMMERS AT THE TIME.
IT SOUNDED LIKE, IF I WAS
UNDERSTANDING IT CORRECTLY, YOU
HEARD AS WELL, THAT WHEN THEY
ARRIVED, THE SUSPECT THEN
ATTACKED PAUL PELOSI WITH THE
HAMMER AND THEN OFFICERS MOVED
IN AND APPREHENDED HIM, BOTH
PAUL PELOSI AND THE SUSPECT WERE
TAKEN TO AN AREA HOSPITAL WHERE
WE'RE TOLD PAUL PELOSI IS
EXPECTED TO FULLY RECOVER,
ACCORDING TO THE STATEMENT WE
GOT FROM NANCY PELOSI'S OFFICE
EARLIER TODAY.
WE ALSO LEARNED THE IDENTITY OF
THE MAN IN CUSTODY.
42-YEAR-OLD DAVID DEPEPI IS HIS
NAME.
WE DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT HIM BUT
WE HAVE LEARNED HE WILL BE
BOOKED ON SEVERAL POTENTIAL
CHARGES, INCLUDING ATTEMPTED
HOMICIDE, BURGLARY, ELDER ABUSE
AND OTHERS.
I THINK THAT SUMS UP THE NEW
INFORMATION WE GOT FROM THIS
PRESS CONFERENCE.
LET'S BRING BACK SOME OF OUR
GUESTS.
I'LL START WITH YOU, EVAN PEREZ.
JUST BRING OUR VIEWERS UP TO
SPEED, NOW THAT WE HAVE A LITTLE
BIT FULLER PICTURE ON WHAT WE
KNOW AT THIS HOUR.
>> YEAH, IT APPEARS THAT THE
POLICE WERE RESPONDING TO SOME
KIND OF WELLNESS CHECK.
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHAT TRIGGERED
THAT.
WHETHER IT WAS A SECURITY SYSTEM
OR WHETHER THAT WAS SOME OTHER
REASON THAT, PERHAPS, MR. PELOSI
WAS ABLE TO GET SOMEONE TO GET
THE POLICE TO GO TO THE
RESIDENCE.
BUT THE FACT IS POLICE WERE
INSIDE THE HOME AND THEY SAW,
ACCORDING TO THE POLICE THERE,
THEY SAW AT LEAST PART OF THE
ATTACK TAKE PLACE, WHICH WAS
MR. PELOSI WAS HOLDING THE
HAMMER WITH THE SUSPECT, AND
THEY SAW HIM CARRY OUT AT LEAST
SOME OF THE ASSAULT HE IS NOW
CHARGED WITH.
THEY WERE ABLE TO TAKE CUSTODY
OF HIM.
WE HAVE NOW GOTTEN A BETTER
PICTURE, A LITTLE BETTER PICTURE
OF THE SUSPECT.
SOME OF OUR FANTASTIC TEAM , OU
INVESTIGATIVE TEAM HERE AT CNN
HAS BEEN LOOKING INTO HIS SOCIAL
MEDIA PRESENCE.
THEY TALKED TO PEOPLE AROUND
HIM, PEOPLE WHO KNOW HIM.
AND THEY PAINT A VERY DISTURBING
PICTURE.
SOMEBODY WHO HAS BEEN OBSESSED
WITH EVERYTHING FROM POLITICAL
THEMES, 2020 ELECTION, FOR
INSTANCE, THEY'VE BEEN -- HE'S
BEEN POSTING YOUTUBE VIDEOS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE 2020
ELECTION AS WELL AS THE JANUARY
6th INVESTIGATIVE COMMITTEE, THE
HOUSE COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING
THE JANUARY 6th ATTACK.
THERE ARE SOME RELIGIOUS THEMES
ARE SOME OF THE VIDEOS AND SO ON
HE'S POSTED ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
AGAIN, IT SORT OF GIVES YOU A
LITTLE BIT OF THE PICTURE OF
WHY, YOU KNOW, THE -- THERE IS
NOW THIS INVESTIGATION THAT
INVOLVES THE FBI AS WELL AS THE
CAPITOL POLICE AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO POLICE DEPARTMENT AS
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET A HANDLE
ON THE MOTIVATION.
IT'S CLEAR FROM WHAT JAMIE
GANGEL HAS HEARD FROM HER
SOURCES THAT THE ATTACKER WENT
THERE LOOKING FOR THE SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
SHE WAS NOT THERE.
OBVIOUSLY, SHE WAS -- IF SHE
WERE, HIS -- HER DETAIL WOULD
HAVE BEEN THERE WITH THE HOME,
AT THE HOME.
BUT SHE WAS NOT THERE.
THAT'S THE REASON WHY THE POLICE
WHEN THEY ARRIVED, THERE WAS NO
OTHER SECURITY AND THEY
INTERRUPTED THE ATTACK AS IT WAS
ONGOING.
AGAIN, A VERY SCARY SCENARIO FOR
AN 82-YEAR-OLD MAN FIGHTING OFF
AN ATTACKER, NOW IDENTIFIED BY
POLICE AS DAVID DEPAPI, 42 YEARS
OLD, WE'RE TOLD AND SOMEONE WHO
WAS POSTING VERY ACTIVELY ON
SOCIAL MEDIA WITH A LOT OF
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, EVERYTHING
RANGING FROM COVID ORIGINS TO
THINGS RELATED TO THE JANUARY
6th INVESTIGATION BY THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE THERE IN THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES.
>> AND AN ACONVEY TANS TELLING
CNN HE SEEMED OUT OF TOUCH WITH
REALITY.
OUR CHIEF RAMSEY IS WITH US
AGAIN.
YOUR REACTION TO WHAT WE'RE
LEARNING ABOUT THIS SUSPECT,
CHIEF.
>> WELL, WE DIDN'T LEARN A LOT
ABOUT THE SUSPECT, BUT THAT'S
BECAUSE THERE'S AN ALL-LOT GOING
ON RIGHT NOW BEHIND THE SCENES.
YOU DO HAVE A NAME AND I'M SURE
SEARCH WARRANTS HAVE BEEN
EXECUTED.
THEY ALREADY PROBABLY,
OBVIOUSLY, HAVE GONE THROUGH ALL
THE SOCIAL MEDIA THEY CAN.
SO, THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
HAVE GONE ON RIGHT NOW.
IT SEEMS TO ME, SOUNDED TO ME
WHEN I WAS LISTENING TO CHIEF
SCOTT, THAT PERHAPS A -- THE
ALARM WAS TRIGGERED WHEN THE
PERSON MADE THE ENTRY INTO THE
HOME.
WHEN YOU HAVE HIGH PROFILE
INDIVIDUALS LIKE THE SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE OR SOMEONE IN YOUR
JURISDICTION, YOUR
COMPUTER-AIDED DISPATCH SYSTEM,
YOUR CAD SYSTEM WOULD FLAG THAT
ADDRESS.
SO IF ANYTHING CAME UP AT ALL,
WHETHER IT WAS A PHONE CALL,
WHETHER AN ALARM OR WHATEVER,
THAT WOULD BE A PRIORITY ONE
RESPONSE.
HE CALLED IT A PRIORITY A,
THAT'S WHAT THEY CALL IT IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
THAT'S GET THERE AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE.
LIGHTS, SIRENS AND SO FORTH.
SO, THAT WOULD GET A VERY, VERY
RAPID RESPONSE.
THAT VERY WELL COULD HAVE BEEN
HOW THEY KNEW THAT SOMETHING WAS
GOING ON AND THEY RESPONDED SO
QUICKLY.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK THEY GAVE SO
LITTLE INFORMATION AND DIDN'T
TAKE QUESTIONS?
>> WELL, BECAUSE THEY HAVE A LOT
OF WORK YET TO DO AND THEY DON'T
WANT TO PUT OUT ANY INFORMATION
THAT'S NOT 100% VERIFIED.
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON BEHIND
THE SCENES.
YOU DON'T KNOW IF THIS PERSON --
YOU DON'T KNOW ANSWERS TO A LOT
OF THAT.
YOU DO KNOW CHIEF SCOTT IS ONE
OF THE BEST POLICE CHIEFS IN THE
COUNTRY.
I KNOW HIM VERY, VERY WELL.
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE THE LEAD ON
THIS.
BEHIND THE SCENES, BELIEVE ME,
THE FBI IS A MAJOR PLAYER IN
THIS ALONG WITH THE U.S. CAPITOL
POLICE.
THEY'RE TRYING TO SEE WHETHER OR
NOT THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE THAT,
PERHAPS, WHEN THEY GO TO HIS
WEBSITE, THERE COULD BE OTHER
NAMES THAT WERE THERE AND
THEY'RE CHECKING AND MAKING SURE
THAT THEY HAVE ADEQUATE
SECURITY.
I'M SPECULATING A BIT, BUT YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY MAY HAVE
FOUND THAT WOULD CAUSE THEM NOT
TO PUT OUT ANY MORE INFORMATION
THAN THEY ALREADY HAVE.
SO, THINGS WILL BE COMING OUT
OVER TIME, NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.